why could tulsi gabbard not win okay
maybe she could win but she'd uh
against recognition
name recognition tulsi needs a little
bit uh uh
i feel tulsi needs to do one more thing
to add to her fame and you know like she
needs a show she needs a
something i don't know what it is like
she needs something to go so this this
is the massive this is the massive
problem with our system you are
convinced
aoc is going to be president united
states one day
but i'm sitting here you're going to
take care of me
20 20. so 20 chance do you give tulsi
gabbard a 20 chance of being president
united states uh i'll tell you right now
a veteran a sitting senator an eloquent
speaker if it weren't for publishing
persona and popularity contest yes she's
unfortunately she's way better than
anyone she's got 1.1 million followers
on twitter unfortunately
and aoc
has 13 million followers on twitter so
now let me go back to tnx 13x so so
roger stone number one is what relevance
constant relevance she's not going to
get relevance from mainstream media
because they're not even going to give
it to the the spotlight they're just not
going to give it to you so what's going
on here she needs to go well next time
she's coming to florida she's coming
here so you got you got what she's going
to go on rogan she's going to go on all
this stuff all these things she needs
she needs another pop i think she needs
another pop like you know trump pulled
from where trump from billionaire trump
pulled from wealthy people trumpful from
apprentice trump from new york trump
from all the after-parties he did trump
pull from golf trump from a lot of
different places right
rock's gonna pull from wrestling rock's
gonna pull from hollywood rock's gonna
pull from bodybuilding like i think
she's not multi-dimensional enough today
to pull that's the only thing i'm
thinking about and aside from that
somebody powerful needs to go and
back her up somebody needs to back her
up if that happens she doesn't need the
other part but somebody needs to do that
and and
i just i just don't know if that's
happening that's a very dangerous place
to be man because basically what you
guys are saying then is that the
mainstream media the
media apparatuses are the people who
choose who has access and who doesn't
right aoc is on tv all the time because
they put her on tv all the time tulsi
gabbard speaks just as much does just as
many instagram lives they never make it
too late you're saying though
so what i'm saying is is that
essentially what
the people there's a very small
percentage of unelected people that run
corporate media that are giving people
enough access to be have a 20 chance as
opposed to not even news
it's not news but what it is is horrible
but it is so dangerous it is horrible
popularity
but it is horrible it is horrible it's
not it's not organic but but i tell you
what my problem with this is so i i've
had the last week i've had calls we've
been
talking about potentially buying a big
paper okay and we've been having calls
and i've made the effort we've called we
we want to make an offer to them anyways
it's it's somebody everybody every one
of you guys knows who this is it's
massive you know who it is
uh and we've been going back and forth
they're playing the whole thing up well
we're not really interested right now
because we're doing so well and all this
other stuff right and we're not really
interested in doing something like that
right now okay because of xyz okay the
one newspaper in america actually making
money
uh uh no so so anyways but the the point
i'm making to you is
i'm doing this because it's a long-term
play okay
the people who oppose what is happening
with all the progressive policies today
in america when is the last time they
had an emergency meeting together that's
a three-day meeting sitting down saying
what the hell is your strategy when's
the last time somebody spearheaded that
to put a strategy in place when because
the left does it all the time when's the
last time the right did it when's the
last time they got together and they
said let's get the biggest media guy
let's get a tulsi in here let's get a
rant in here let's get iran in here
let's get all these guys in here what do
we need to do let's talk about a
strategy and somebody needs to be the
strategy somebody needs to be the
general manager the head coach how about
we do this how about we did that
if that doesn't happen all this other
stuff is just a bunch of lip service so
you have to fight against mainstream
media they're not going away you got to
play your game you got a forbes magazine
that sells to china for 95 what are you
doing like how do you let a magazine
like that go away fortune is now left
money is now left inc is now left forbes
is now left what the hell are you doing
capitalism is about to be gone so what
are some so all of these small
opportunities that keep going away
capitalists should buy all these
magazines to keep this con concept of
capitalism going now you're hearing
socialism is not a bad approach in
forbes magazine you tell me how that
makes any sense it's like ayn rand
selling her paper and all of a sudden
they're talking about social is a good
idea yeah that doesn't make any sense
yeah it's not really an article in
forbes yeah yeah so they're talking
about that yeah so
the point the point is
these things can these things are
happening and there's not a strategy to
fight against what gerard is talking
about if you're not going to have a
strategy in place i'm sorry you deserve
to get your ass handed i can't tell you
dude that that there's so many people
that feel helpless in the moment
specifically because of what you just
said that they
they feel like what's even the point
this is an unwinnable battle like this
culture
i know what you're saying right but
there's like there's you're right
there's not that guy saying listen if
you disagree this is what you got to do
do this this this and this do that like
yeah i couldn't agree with you more man
i could not agree with your ppd even if
you're saying if the right did have a
strategy
and i'm not even being sarcastic would
it even matter because trump owns that
party no of course it would matter by
the way that's part of a strategy though
you have to know he is in the strategy
so somebody has to go and have a combo
with him
to talk to him that's part of the
strategy he's going to speak to him and
will he will listen to everything the
right person can who who's trump
listening ever the right person is can
and like the right
what matters more to your country or
your brand country no no not to you to
trump somebody needs to have a
conversation with him that's actually a
legitimate question what matters more to
your country or your name that's the
question
i'd love to see here his answer because
because a follow-up question after that
is what
here's what's a follow-up question so
you asked the question president uh
donald j trump what's more important to
you your last name and your legacy or
your country what do you think he's
going to answer
what do you think he's going to answer i
think he's going to say everything that
he's built his legacy his brand i think
he's going to say his country i think
they're intertwined yeah yeah i think
he's going to say his country then the
follow-up question is what perfect so if
the people in the party you're
representing
no longer think you're the person to
help save the country are you okay
voting for somebody that can get the job
done to save the country you care so
much about that's a great hypothetical
but he owns that party the the party
wants him i don't but what i'm have you
seen the latest results what i'm trying
to tell you is so what's the alternative
you don't have that meeting you don't
have that sit down you don't have that
conversation you don't have that
strategy session the right's going to
constantly sit on the sidelines and say
oh we can't do nothing about it oh
shucks
eight more years oh it's you know if he
is the
so what are you saying that if he
shouldn't run that hey you're gonna we
need you to be a cheerleader for pence
or cheerleader for
somebody else or somebody who knows how
to deal with big egos who has no
aspirations to run needs to get in the
mix and have those conversations behind
closed doors and nobody needs to know
about those conversations yeah somebody
who is like a qualified guy who can who
can go have those conversations talk to
george soros
i hear you yeah loud and clear okay i
think he's had quote unquote adults in
the room whether that's general mattis
or general kelly or whether that's i
don't think mattis is the guy though
okay whoever it is but you know what
kind of a person in five years we
haven't identified the guy yeah for five
years we've been saying well somebody
needs to talk to trump and you know talk
a little sense and the only name that
has come up that people were like okay
maybe he'll listen is ivanka and i'm
pretty sure she and jared kushner are
done with politics they're having a nice
little life down in south beach building
a house
they're not you think kushner is going
back into the white house no way they're
done with politics no i don't know about
it there's no way they're done with
politics other than her who else does he
actually listen to a legitimate question
so to do to think a person like that
doesn't exist is a form of giving up
right to think a person like that
doesn't exist as a form of saying
there's nothing i can do but i feel
helpless i don't come from the
helpless community to to think that
there's nothing we can do about it no
the the conversation and the approach
matters if if you don't know how to
approach somebody based with their
personality the right way you're not
going to get results okay it's all in
the approach so if you go and say matter
style who the hell are you talking to me
like this what do you it it's got to be
the right person
with zero threat with zero everything
you save protect it all of that just
have that conversation so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]